Speaker 1: Let's go to another Ben.
This time we'll go to Ben from France.
Ben from France.
I assume this is your calling from the country
of France, is that correct?
Speaker 3: This is true.
Welcome.
Hey, David.
Yeah, I'm actually American, but I've been
living in France.
It's about 2018, so it's been.
It's been good here.
Speaker 1: What are you over there?
Having a health care without paying for it
and stuff like that?
Do you think you're better than us or.
Speaker 3: Yeah, Yeah.
Just for a quick anecdote.
Like I, I have had a small fracture on my
elbow a couple of years ago, and without health
insurance, I had just the basic Social Security.
I paid like €50 for a couple of X-rays and
medication and all that, so.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Right.
Well, that's pretty good.
And are you in Paris or elsewhere?
Speaker 3: I'm going to be in Paris this upcoming
couple of weeks, but I live in Britain usually.
Speaker 1: Oprah I have never been, but I
hear it's delightful.
Speaker 3: It is.
Yeah.
This is where actually my, my, my mom is from.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to have to get up
there.
All right?
I get those buckwheat greens, You know, I
need those buckwheat crepes.
Speaker 3: Yeah, not.
Not quite the ones you have in the U.S., right?
Speaker 1: Not exactly.
All right.
Well, I mean, not.
Not Take up more of your time, Please.
Go ahead.
Speaker 3: That's all right.
Yeah, I know.
So I've been thinking, you know, here for
a while and watching the US content for a
while.
And I notice it's really the culture wars
is taking up more and more of the air, it
seems like.
And we don't quite have the same thing here
in Europe.
We do have somewhat of it.
But you know, I, I still think like the the
workers issues and economic policy don't get
quite the quite the discussion that they should.
My I guess my question for you is, does this
concern you at all?
And like what economic policy do you think
would you like to focus more on if you had
more of an opportunity to?
For example, I've been writing for a while
on universal basic income.
I think unions are great, but unless everyone
has a union, it's unions can become also kind
of classist in their own sense.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
No, listen, I mean, there is a sickness here
in the United States, and I follow a lot of
foreign foreign to the US content creators,
certainly many in France, Italy and Spain,
as well as in my birth country of Argentina
and elsewhere.
And what I what I hear many of them say either
publicly or sometimes in private communications
that I have with some of these folks is that
much of the world is looking at the United
States culture war and saying it seems like
very serious mental illness, quite frankly,
or short of it, like it's just the country
has gone completely insane and the stories
around labor and workers rights and getting
to you know, we're at a point where we don't
really we could eliminate poverty, we could
certainly eliminate hunger.
We could certainly get everybody access to
health care.
And we're arguing about, you know, like I
said earlier, Florida's banning Holocaust
textbooks because they're woke and someone
showed a movie with a gay character.
So now that's an investigation.
It is a form of insanity.
And when you step outside of the U.S., even
briefly, like I did a couple of weeks ago
when I went to London, you realize that, number
one, this isn't going on in the rest of the
world.
And number two, we look insane here in the
United States.
Speaker 3: Right?
So I guess.
Well, which which it's it's true.
But then at the end of the day, you have to
think like, okay, what what kind of things
should we focus on if we had if ideally we
could in the culture while wasn't sucking
up so much air.
Speaker 1: Well, certainly we should be focusing
on economics, inequality, workers rights.
As I mentioned, we should be coming together
to say, hey, here's what we're going to do
about climate change and we're going to find
the balance between people getting to live
the lives they want and also not destroying
the planet.
Here's how we're going to manage emerging
technology, and we're going to have logical
conversations about emerging technology.
Here's a forward looking energy plan that's
going to get us increasingly on renewables.
I mean, there's there's no shortage of things
that we could and should be focusing on.
But to a degree, you know, you can't ignore
all of the cultural stuff the right is doing
because if you do and they simply win on all
of it, it hurts our ability to deal with all
of those other things I just mentioned.
So it's a very tough situation.
Speaker 3: It is.
Yes.
And I hope you get the opportunity to do a
little bit more.
I mean, I don't watch your every single video
or email that you have, but I do hope that
you are able to, you know, kind of kind of
cover a little bit more of that and focus
more about that in the future.
Again, universal basic income is something
that I've been thinking about for a while.
It's an interesting solution to me.
But obviously that's a that's a very big conversation.
And I think you would be nice to see different
ideas and and kind of like taking a little
bit more from ideas that are happening elsewhere
in the world.
Not so much France.
Absolutely.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Ben, are you at some kind of carnival or carousel?
There's a strange it's almost like a ding
dong truck in the background.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
You know, actually, I was I was kind of trying
to, like, look at that.
I thought I thought it was coming from this
area because I don't know where it's coming
from.
My clothes are all my browsers and everything.
I don't know where that's coming from.
Speaker 1: But there's not an ice cream truck
outside of your window or anything.
Speaker 3: No, we don't have those here.
Wow.
We just have.
Yeah.
Now, no ice cream trucks, unfortunately, But.
But I'm okay with the lower cost
of health care, and that's very good.
Speaker 1: I guess that seems like
a fair trade.
Ben from France, thanks very much.
Speaker 3: No problem.
All right.
Speaker 1: There goes Ben